in so you were at UCLA 1968-69
65 through 73 got it well 1969 we know
what happened there it was the summer of
love and you had the Vietnam war protest
against Johnson uh Johnson's not going
to run again and women's lib blew up and
all that happened if there was a place
where rebelling against Society started
in the US than Berkeley was the Wuhan
lab in 1969 Berkeley was crazy did you
see it you were
and you're a young guy high education
you're going to into law what did you
see I didn't want to go into law I
wanted to go into physics okay well
still you're an incredibly smart guy and
perceptive what did you see at that time
that you said wow if this keeps up we're
in trouble or if this did you see some
tipping points I didn't think we were
going to be in trouble because it took a
spin that I had not anticipated and I
only vaguely recognized at the time and
that's what Hollywood did with it
because they had an agenda they were
trying to push and they took advantage
of circumstances and did it now what
went on is we had civil rights but civil
rights got people used to the idea
of large groups of people coming out and
doing stuff before that when you got
large groups out typically it had
something to do with a union matter or
employment or something like that or
workers of the World Unite yes and all
of that and you had these kinds of
things but you had it glamorized and you
had it covered in real time by
television which was not what you had
before so the idea of a bunch of people
being out somewhere carrying on because
they didn't like something was
publicized and put in the heads of just
about
everybody so that set the St stage for
large scale protest anti-war protest and
such like because the Nom was a very
unpopular
War now people look at stuff like the
January 6 thing where 180
people committed what 50 years ago would
have been such a small blip nobody would
have paid attention to
it uh you had situations in DC 50 years
ago all around the country where you got
15 20 30 40,000 people breaking stuff up
you had the uprisings in the large
cities
where disenchanted people burnt the
place down I remember 65 August standing
on a lowrise hill in Los Angeles and a
pivoted
360 and you couldn't see the sun because
the smoke was so thick looked like being
in a war zone this the original Watts
Riots right
and that kind of
thing is something that today's people
don't get what they call a protest was
just people got bored and came out and
didn't have anything else to do with
trying to get laid you know but
nowadays
um it's a sense of proportion uh we
lost maybe somewhere around 5,000 folk
over in the sand pile over a 20 some
year
period I hate it but that used to be a
weekly tally back in the
60s see everybody in America knew
somebody body that was dead from the N
MH uh and we had people around that were
vigorous young and they had been in
Korean some people that were not even
getting too gr been in World War Two and
then the grayhair folk had been in World
War I so there was a great deal of
difference about what folk felt they
were entitled to then and then you were
feeling entitled to the
opportunity to do for yourself now
people have this idea that the
entitlement is somebody doing it for you
Cradle to
grave uh remaining in the Cradle you
make a great point about demonstrations
I mean you compare January 6th to Kent
State Kent State demonstrations got so
bad and so rowdy they called the
national guard shot forign armed
students and broke it up I mean they
shot more than foron armed students but
but that's how many died yeah and you
look at January 6 and you look at the'
60s look at 1968 after in in Detroit you
know the convention's on the inside and
there's a mass demonstration extremely
violent on the outside and it's not
people without opinion but it was so
different yeah uh you got 28,000 people
involved in that thing in Chicago in
1968 with the democratic
convention uh I remember at UCLA where
we had a student population 60 65,000
full-time students and there were some
occasions when LAPD swept through there
and there were just continuous riots
going on over hours in this complex with
60 some thousand people being there so
what people call a big upset now we just
looked at all what else is what happened
in the news you know well there I mean
really what happened was interesting so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here